good afternoon everyone and uh Happy uh
Friday welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from
the University of Virginia and I'm very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series the lecture
Series has been supported by uva's
integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and
through grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme
has been data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19
pandemic where each Friday we've enjoyed
presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise the
opportunities and the hurdles which are
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of the covid-19
virus these include but are not limited
to delayed Health checkups and
treatments mental health concerns drug
abuse increased obesity and the long
lingering health effects associated with
the SARS covid-19 virus participants
selected for our biomedical data science
Innovation lab program will be
leveraging these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
beautiful Seattle Washington in June of
2020 of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
final speaker of our series Dr Vivian
banazzi she chief chief medical
biomedical data scientist and managing
director
um at Deloitte Dr banazzi received a
Bachelor of Science in medical
laboratory science from the University
of Canberra in Australia and MSC in
Pharmacology from the University of
Melbourne and a PhD in molecular
pharmacology and computational biology
from the University of Melbourne she is
a highly experienced biomedical data
scientist who's always had a passion for
understanding how data science methods
and Technologies can be applied to
biomedical data to yield a better
understanding of biology her work is
focused on more easily being able to
share access analyze find and provide
attribution to biomedical data and tools
regardless of geographic location size
complexity so as to enable new
biomedical discoveries she is a thought
leader concerning the development of a
data Commons a cloud-based platform
supporting the ability to to easily
utilize the fair principles for
biomedical data and tools importantly as
a 2023 bdsil Mentor she recognizes
Champions and advocates for team science
approaches for major biomedical research
Endeavors and this is work that she
carries on today working at Deloitte so
in bringing to a close our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar Series this spring today's
lecture is entitled towards a data
Commons for biomedicine or the amount of
biomedical data continues to grow at
ever faster rates and Vivian will
describe for us some of the community
experience the team science approaches
need needed for developing a data
Commons that is this interoperable
infrastructure which co-locates data
storage and compute with common analytic
tools and she will present several case
studies and underscore the importance of
Team science in doing data science as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube if
you're watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us and for having
joined us throughout the year also our
specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are strongly encouraged to
submit any questions they have via the
chat feature in the zoom sessions I will
synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so the lecture and with that
welcome Vivian we are absolutely so
pleased that you're able to join us and
share with us uh some of your thoughts
and your work and ideas
thank you so much Jack I really
appreciate it I'm looking forward to
today
um so today what I'd like to do is
follow on off that wonderful
introduction there by Jack but first I'd
like to just give a little bit of an
understanding about what I do and
Deloitte and I hope that also touches on
the aspect that I think Jack's been
really talking about which is team
science so as Jack stated before I'm the
chief biomedical data scientist and also
a managing director at Deloitte I
co-lead the biomedical data science
group within deloitte's known as BDS and
what we have in my team is a diverse set
of Matrix skills for the various
projects that we do and I've listed some
of those out here I have quite a few
folks in my team that are PhD Ms
biomedical scientists of some sort
almost everyone in my team
they come from a biomedical background
but they understand about data or
metadata they don't necessarily code but
they can and but clearly they understand
the constructs of those data and also
the meaning of that data we also have
data scientists that can also be some of
our PhD scientists but we also have data
scientists that don't necessarily have
that background and I just listed a
couple of things that we use on a
regular basis here but the rest of the
team is also made up of important
different skills so Cloud Engineers we
have cyber Security Experts we do UI ux
design we also do importantly project
Management's really complicated large
projects require very capable skills in
putting things together these are not
simple
timelines these are really complex
management plans to ensure that we can
actually meet the deadlines that we have
proposed and work closely with our
clients but we also have to be able to
communicate both with our clients and
other people that are not necessarily in
our field so we work with marketing
folks within Deloitte but we also have
science writers within our team and then
because we're dealing with large
contracts mostly with the government
which I'll speak about in a minute we
have to work with legal conflicts of
interest deloitte's large
so you have to ensure and we do a lot of
auditing so we have to ensure this in a
conflicts of interest we deal with
contracts financials and pricings each
one of the people that represents that
skill in my team is Matrix 10 for
different parts of a particular project
and we work really hard at trying to
make sure that those overlaps come in at
different times and people may not be
skilled in pricing if they're a
scientist but they understand what that
needs to bring and that theme is
something I'm going to try and sort of
thread through this that
interdisciplinary nature of the way we
do science and the people is critical
for success and being able to drive the
future that we handle with digital
ecosystems
the work I primarily do is in the
government and public sector so I work
with HHS agencies primarily I work with
NIH and CDC but the rest of my team and
my co-lead Jurgen Klink works with some
of the others listed here we also work
with the VA and also military health and
I do refer amount of work with health
non-profits in my field they're often
disease related or organ related but
they're all dealing with very similar
issues that the government is dealing
with as well
the work I do is we provide advisory
support or effort if an organization is
trying to understand how to use its data
or to develop data governance uh we also
provide analytics services for managing
storing in and primarily interconnecting
an organization's scientific data we can
connect it to its Enterprise data that
is not related to the science we
understand the connectivity pieces in
there but we tend to primarily focus on
the science so that's what we do and I'm
trying to make this go forward
so what are we going to talk about today
well today we're going to talk about
biomedical data as a key element in
these complex and evolving digital
ecosystems I think all of you know
something about biomedical data
by the end of this you'll know more
about it but data in itself does not sit
on its own and I think understanding how
it fits into the ecosystem is important
because we often think of them as
individual elements and that can create
its issues also depending on what you
come from if you're a pure biomedical
scientist or a pure data scientist you
will see the world in a different way so
when you're looking at an ecosystem we
have to work together both technically
but we also have to work together as
people to understand it
I want to point out a couple of things
as I go through it's an evolving pla
place for looking at digital ecosystems
and they're not well connected or
interoperable I don't think that's
malicious it's just the nature of a
large collection of data that you need
to work on
at times it's difficult to understand
where to start
but if you do look at improving
interoperability it improves the ability
to share and reuse data and to further
discoveries and I'll bring up a couple
of points here but I think the obvious
one as I think everyone knows with
covid-19 we didn't have a really good
way of sharing our data to start with
and it became really apparent that we
needed to do better if we were going to
work together to try and solve how to
treat uh track it Etc
and lastly I'm going to talk about how
all of this fits together in terms of
the data Commons and how that can
support data infrastructure
interoperability because it's really
these two things data and the the
systems that it sits on that have to
work together in order to be able to
drive Discovery and better understand
that data
so so I'm not going to talk about this
and the reason why I want to bring this
up is because almost every talk people
ask me what programming language should
I learn it's depending what you need to
do so I'm not going to go through this
it is important but it's a rabbit hole
that I don't want to get into today
what I do think is important is
these topics they're equally as
important as as that
the skills of writing code are important
I certainly spent many years doing this
but it's understanding the context of
what you're trying to do that's equally
as important I can find many data
scientists that can code in python or R
but not that many that understand the
context of what they're writing for and
why and if you don't do that you won't
really understand what you're doing in
the first place and secondly you just
create more silos and lack of
interconnectivity
so
what I think is equally important to
draw it here is when you're looking at
ecosystems is you need to understand the
holistic picture of what you're trying
to do scientifically understand the
context of the analysis you're trying to
do you have to understand how to use
data securely particularly when you're
looking at biomedical data because it's
it's often controlled access it deals
with human data and authentication and
authorization is important not so much
the application is in the tooling here
that I'm talking about it's just you
need to know who's permitted to use it
and who is not particularly when you're
dealing with human data
what is the business value of data I'm
going to come to this again a little
later
you may not think about this as an
academic institution but it is a
business of data organizations are
businesses and if you don't understand
why you're generating that data or how
you're transforming it in some way then
you're not really understanding what
real value is going to be inside an
organization whether that be academic or
commercial
I think it's really important to have a
set of skills that you can communicate
to non-technical members of your team
whether they be non-scientists
non-computer scientists none of the
above that are really working in the
legal application of some of these I've
had many examples uh in working at
Deloitte where I'm working with other
team members that have none of the
backgrounds and computer science or bio
but they really need to understand what
we're trying to do to ensure that we
really can deliver and if there are any
concerns about that
I think a really important one which is
close to me but I think it's it's
something that's important to increasing
number of people's people is what are
you doing to support interoperability
shareability and reuse of your data
tools and your results if all you're
doing is something in a microcosm that
may be valuable but I think if we are
able to share our information and our
data that's going to help with new
discoveries
I think it's also under important to
understand how to use data responsibly
and that really comes from a diverse set
of skills one of the skills that I
haven't listed before was an ethicist
but we are increasingly looking at that
because as I think we've seen recently
with AI generating tools the issue there
becomes how are you ethically and
responsibly using some of these tools
for the outcomes and the impact on on
on people's lives particularly when
you're talking about health and you're
also dealing with health disparities
so I think really it's very important
that when we bring teams together to
solve these problems they have those
diverse skills and they listen to each
other another really important skill
and I think understanding that data is
really part of a complex and evolving
digital ecosystem is important so you
can bring your technology skills to this
but you need to be thinking about these
things all the time I urge my team all
the time to be thinking about these
kinds of things that are outside the
norm of what they do on a daily basis
because I really think It ultimately
provides the best way of
an outcome from a project and also the
best outcome when difficulties arise
within the team to be able to talk to
each other and figure things out
right so I'm going to talk a little bit
now around the data itself so what do I
mean by biomedical Big Data again I'm
just going to point out some things here
some of these may be obvious some are
not
um dodo comes in various forms in
biomedical data so there's Imaging types
of data I've shown those here there's
genomics data which is a really big it's
certainly been over the last 20 years
growing large number data set but also
protein folding protein data is very
large spectro data is pretty huge uh
electronic health records which were
usually all written on paper and now
almost all electronic and they're
increasing in number of volume and
there's always wearables which I think
most of you will have come across as
well and that the volume of that data is
really huge so it's a large set of data
we're talking about
so what does it really when I say what
does it make it big well it's volume
there's a lot of it in terms of size
velocity the rate of which it's coming
out is very high and it's getting faster
the variety which is many different data
types there are increasing number of
data types and subtypes as time goes on
and veracity which is this lovely term
applying to really you know what's the
quality of that data and if we don't pay
attention to any of these things then
we're not going to understand how to
deal with the data itself
but all of these things together are
important but what's it really pointing
to and I think the key thing here is
that we're in a digital economy and that
data itself has value and that that data
is actually Central to that digital
economy
in particular here I think I want to
point out that a digital economy is
characterized by using data to gain a
business advantage and as I mentioned
before I said the word business yes
academic institutions are a business and
I think you have to think about that for
how you're thinking about what your
digital economy is in whatever
organization you are and that the
organizations of the future have to be
born digital if you don't you you'll
really be at a disadvantage I think this
new economy is really important to think
about it as a digital economy
so I think in the future and now I think
true organizations will be defined by
their digital assets and how they will
be leveraged so in scientific
organizations uh scientific digital
asset I'll use the term data uh
throughout the rest of this talk but I
really mean any digital asset and that
could be data and metadata coming from a
specific experiment that you wrote down
and digitized or it came straight off a
machine
it could be analysis that you've done uh
that you've taken data from a machine it
could be the metadata that you've taken
from that data that came from machine or
was transformed but it also applies to
artifacts like software the analytics
the workflows any services like apis you
have with it that is also a digital
asset the documentation which is really
important the uh the Sops the readme's
anything else that you have Journal
articles and increasingly in the digital
world blogs blogs YouTube
Etc I think we're talking about that
today this is being streamed
I think what we're trying to get at here
is that the most successful organization
organizations of the future will be
those that can really leverage their
digital assets and transform those into
an interconnected digital ecosystem if
you just have lots of digital assets and
you can't connect them they're just dots
in the system really is that
transformational knowledge will come
from understanding the
interconnectedness of that digital
ecosystem
foreign
so let's look at some of the issues
around biomedical data there are many
and it's what's stopping some of that
interconnectivity but there is some hope
and I'll bring that a little bit later
in this talk
so I think in the case of certainly in
the academic world the journal article
is still often seen as the end goal that
means that the data that supports that
General article is a means to an end and
it's low value and I think some of that
is the lack of incentives around this
and that is funding agencies in general
have prioritized by medical outcomes and
consider interoperability a secondary
interest so essentially publish your
paper doesn't matter about the data it's
okay you needed to use it for the paper
but then we're done and that data is not
is not fair this is a term that is being
used increasingly uh both in the
commercial and the academic world and
that is relating to data's findable
accessible interoperable and
reproducible when you pay attention to
this this really allows connectivity
within data
now I have a short hopefully it'll show
up this is a two-minute video some folks
may have seen this before I think a
couple of thoughts here is this is the
issue of what happens with data when you
pay attention only to the journal
article the other interesting thing
about this little video is that if it
will play is that this was done in 2012
and really the issues haven't changed
that much so I'm just going to play it
now and hopefully it will run
hi hello my name is Dr Judy benign I'm
an oncologist at NYU School of Medicine
hello Dr Judy benign I read your article
about B cell functions it was very
interesting I think that I could use the
data for my work on pancreatic cancer
I am not an oncologist I know but I
think I could use the data for my work
on pancreatic cancer
oh
so do you have the data everything you
need to know is in the article no what I
need is the data will you share your
data I am not sure that will be possible
but your work is in PubMed Central and
was funded by NIH that is true um it was
published in science which requires that
you share your data I did publish and
science then I am requesting your data
can I have a copy of your data
everything you need to know is in the
article
no
I am not sure where my data is but
surely you saved your data I did I saved
it on a USB drive where is the USB drive
it is in the Box
it is in the box at home I just moved
but can I use your data
there are many boxes
well
I forgot to label the boxes
all right so I think now we see this is
a problem that is consistent uh and we
still can see it being a problem at the
moment
uh there's a reference here
um
down the bottom here if you have the
slides you can actually watch the
entirety uh of this YouTube video it's
actually quite long I just took a small
slice of it
but you can see that the shareability of
data is a problem when you only look at
Journal articles
so some additional considerations around
the problems with biomedical data data
is cheap to generate and costly to store
in local servers that has been problem
for quite a long time
um lately what's been going on certainly
over the last uh several years now it's
cheaper to store on cloud in the case of
biomedicine gcp Google or AWS are the
primary stores but that's changing as
well but they're the primary ones at the
moment
you also have issues where you get
multiple copies of the same data in
different locations and sometimes on the
same Cloud so you can have five copies
of the data they're all in gcp but
they're all in separate accounts and no
one is able to share the data
or wants to
there's also a case of building data
resources that cannot be easily found by
others and that data resources are not
connected to each other and cannot share
data or tools and the focus of late has
been to build on cloud platforms and
tools and really it's all about the tool
not the data when you do this and you
have these kinds of issues it creates
silos and it creates difficulty in using
the data even just for a small number of
experiments and most researchers really
want to be able to share data to have
new discoveries and to share it in order
to find out different things from their
own data or other people's data
but when the incentives are unaligned
this is what you get
so what's changing though I think
there's a number of things that are
actually occurring at the moment and
they're all in the positive realm so
number one research repositories for
data are increasing where there's a
requirement for when you store the data
there's some consistency in the way you
store it rather than just being stored
at a pi site
the other one is the landmark paper
around Fair which I think came out in
2016 by Wilkinson I've just got a copy
up here this is really pushing the idea
of that findable accessible
interoperable reproducibility of data
and guiding ideas and policies where
it's really driving that kind of
adoption is really important additional
to that in underlying pieces is
increased use of metadata and
consistency in that metadata having
unique identifiers associated with data
that are not driven just by one
organization but an agreed-upon set of
identifiers open sharing and open data
standards and software okay I think
that's also driving that you can adopt
New pieces at fonts like Lego blocks if
you they're all the same and you can
re-share these
NIH data sharing policies have been
evolving as well I've worked at NIH but
I've also been consuming of some of
their data and support some of their
projects as of 2023 they and at the
bottom here is the link for the URL NIH
released the 2023 data management and
sharing policies which are substantial
and they are really moving towards
fairness of data
and I think that's really driving it
from a funding and a policy perspective
and requiring groups to spend more time
to think about those things and then
there are examples of a Community Driven
organizations I've given one example
here which is the Global Alliance for
Global health genomics and Global Health
which is ga4gh but there are others like
RDA the research data Alliance and many
others that are open standards for using
data and tools and Adoption of those
results in a consistent use of data and
also systems that actually support it so
I think there's a lot of supporting this
in the community and I think there's a
lot of drive to do a better job of that
I think the fair principles here drive
data to become the currency of an
organization and make it reusable and
much more easily shareable as a resource
and the policies that promote that data
sharing via VIA Fair help change the
culture inside an organization whatever
that is to ensure that you can create
connectivity of data
okay so let's move on we've talked a lot
about data but there's more to it than
that and that is we also need to think
about a digital ecosystem that allows
transactions to occur on Fair data at
scale and that's pretty common
biomedicine because the data is large
and diverse we're talking petabytes and
above and you need to be able to do that
you're not going to be doing that any on
anything except some sort of computer
and the concept of a data Commons which
has come from a number of people is
really about looking at digital assets
and infrastructures including software
and all the other pieces that support
use of data and making them fair so can
you reuse apis that have a consistent
form is your data in a form that's
consistent with some sort of data
standard that's what we're getting at
when you do those transactions at scale
with data that's and digital assets and
infrastructures that are fair that
allows to look at interoperability
so a data Commons facilitates data and
infrastructure interoperability and a
data Commons can be a cloud platform but
often isn't and I'm going to talk a
little bit about that
but first before we go there what do I
mean by a data Commons this is just
really a principle here it's really in
three parts there's some form of compute
it's usually Cloud but not always you
can have on-prem or and there are also
hybrids there's a data layer of some
sort and then there's a collection of
tools and services and they range in a
couple of different types at the lowest
layer there are services that basically
interconnect with the data in some way
move it around they're not related to
any of the science but they prepare the
data in some way to be able to make it
used it's also important to have an
authentication layer there in order to
be particularly if it's protector data
in the case if you're dealing with NIH
data dbgap is one of those controlled
Access Data you want to ensure that that
data is truly secure in allowing access
to only people that are authorized to
use it but you also need services to
index data to be able to run containers
and workflows and then you have over the
top of that tools that actually do the
analysis in a scientific form
and not everyone in the biomedical world
is able to code and so what we need is
user interfaces and portals that allow
scientists without that kind of
background to be able to interact with
the data in a useful meaningful way and
they can do experiments
so really that the layer of a Commons is
in three parts the compute platform
which is usually cloud data and some
form of software services and tools that
interact with the data but as I
mentioned before what you wanted those
tools and data to be is to be fair to
apply and to comply the best possible
standards that are available at the
moment so when you're comparing two
things with a software or data these
things are interoperable
and so I've got a little icon here down
in the corner it's really a little
platform if you want to use it that that
uses Fair principles and I'm going to
use that diagram and again
so moving on let's talk about some of
the challenges that we have with data
commons's
I think we have a number of these
and if I can get my slide to go
all right so the last five years we've
seen a huge explosion of academic and
Commercial Cloud platforms and quite a
number of them claim to be data Commons
it's but there are differences that
difference is is merging which is good
but there are differences so collab
platform looks like a data Commons and
it's basically Cloud Plus data plus
tools
but the data Commons is really trying to
apply that fairness which is what are
you doing with consistency of using data
standards or best practices to your data
and your software in that system so that
when you're going to work with another
system it's using the same principles
the problem we have is that cloud
platforms look like a Commons but
they're not they tend to be mostly
driven as an internal source
so let me describe a little more of what
I mean by this Cloud platforms really
are built with a premise of simplifying
data and often a slick UI
they're optimized
essentially for a very specific purpose
and often a very specific data type or
data types a small number of data the
reason for that is they're trying to
look at a series of use cases for some
sort of scientific use case and they
have two three five maybe data sets
which they bring in-house so they store
the data on cloud specifically for this
particular thing
the datron tools are fair enough within
the confines of the specific Cloud
platform what happens inside those is
these Cloud platforms often have
project-based data schemas they're not
necessarily compliant with the current
standards and they're not necessarily
using utilizing any Fair terms or any
other assets whether it be software or
data
within the platform and what happens
over time with these platforms too is
the data schemas and then conformed
entirely for the platform and they
evolve away if they started from a
standard they evolve away from it simply
because they have an internal Focus to
drive to an outcome
um it is also true that some of these
standards are not available at the time
so they have to create something but
what happens is you get an insularity in
terms of the data schema specific for
that cloud platform and that causes
problems if you're trying to get one
Cloud platform to talk to another one
they also prioritize internal
capabilities over external connections
that support interoperability by that I
mean they prioritize the kind of
software they do to drive to what their
outcome is
so in this case and I point this out
here in the incentives often these Cloud
platforms are driven to some sort of
biomedical outcome by the definition of
some use cases they have when you do
that you build all of the software and
all of the data that comes to that is
aligned with whatever that outcome is it
is not aligned with being necessarily
interoperable that is not the first
thing that is thought about here and as
time goes on you that becomes more and
more complex and it becomes more and
more insular to the actual Cloud plot
from itself this is what I mean by
prioritizing internal capabilities
rather than trying to externalize Via
interoper interoperability
the incentives are not aligned either it
is not to and the incentives are not to
interconnect with other Cloud platforms
the funding agencies really prioritize
biomedical outcomes and they really
often have considered interoperability a
second interest if you spend a lot of
time doing interoperability and you
don't look at the outcome and you have a
funding stream from NIH and they're
looking for an outcome this causes a
clash so people will naturally just
build a system that will go for that
outcome
the commercial clouds are really not
that different in this context and that
is the commercial Cloud platforms must
maintain market share and drive sales to
their platforms so the more users they
have that are willing to pay for their
platform they're going to keep modifying
that so it's really easy for the user to
keep coming back and using whatever
their platform is there is no incentive
here for commercial platforms to
interconnect with others because they
would simply lose market share
and this is just created a great deal of
essentially vendor lock-in whether you
be academic or commercial and they
become essentially silos
but there are some issues here to be
fair to the cloud platforms that I think
points to this issue that ecosystems
really are evolving and that is theory
is as a term and application is
extremely complex and very time
consuming to achieve effectively I don't
think we haven't achieved an optimal yet
I think we're still trying to work it
through because we understand that the
shareability of data and the ReUse of it
is important for cost and also for
achieving discoveries
Fair itself is an evolving landscape for
example there's an increasing number of
data and Tool standards and best
practices they're changing they're being
upgraded updated every day and new ones
are coming out as we have new types of
data new types of Standards around
software are coming out as well before
it was just a tool now there's
consistency around the workflows because
often when you're doing biomedical
studies you're looking at collections of
data and collection of workflows because
it's a collection of tools that you're
using to do the analysis
and I think interoperability is a
particularly complex and thorny issue
it's complex to do it's uh doesn't
immediately seem to be of much benefit
and if you have to drive to an outcome
and that's where your funding is coming
from you're not going to spend time
doing interoperability
so I think that cloud platforms have
really proliferated proliferated here
because academic funding agencies and I
think commercial companies do prioritize
the immediate outcomes over
interconnectivity and reusive data
and I think we have to come to a balance
here and I think we've got there yet
because if you just do interconnectivity
and reuse of data without an outcome why
are you doing it
on the other hand if you're just doing
an outcome and you're building it on use
cases those are fairly brittle and
you're only going to build a system that
handles three or four of them so this
balance is where there's a lot of
discussion at the moment in the
community and understanding where that
sits is very important
so back to team science a little bit
here
this is where a matrixed team that has
different skills can understand these
balances you may be coming from a
software engineering perspective you may
be coming from a biology perspective you
may be coming from an outcome
perspective where you don't know
anything about tools
and I think having those voices heard
and being able to listen to each other
will drive to a balance between these
two things the outcome and the
interconnectivity
so some additional things here to think
about
about what's changing and things that
are I think improving this so the
picture at the top of this is kind of
pointing to this which is
left picture there at the top is what I
described as Cloud platforms that don't
have fairness and then data Commons is
that do I think you're getting a
blending of those two because there's an
understanding that there's value to do
that
it's not perfect but I think it's
starting to happen a lot more and I
think there's a number of reasons for
that
so there's increasing examples of value
of sharing data effectively it's become
really important I raised this at the
beginning of this talk covert 19. that
was pretty clear fairly early on that we
had an inability to know where the data
was be able to share it and to be able
to do something with it so where were
the cases where were they happening what
was the level of spread who was dying
who was getting sick what was
comorbidities all of that kind of pieces
of information were in different silos
across the country and I think a network
of people that had interdisciplinary
skills
uh really cried to look at this to try
and solve that problem and I think this
isn't one example of a number that is
showing that when you can share your
data effectively you can get to good
outcomes quickly but you need to think
about that interconnectivity
in order to be able to do that or you're
spending an awful lot of time data
cleaning and data wrangling
I think organizations are recognizing
the value of consistent and shareable
data they're realizing or the example I
gave above about covert that when you do
that it gives you a valuable outcome but
you have to spend a little time up front
to clean your data and spend time to
make it interoperable and aligned with
Fair principles
I think funding agencies are proactively
supporting data sharing policies and
open data tool and standards for example
as I mentioned before nih's new 2023
data sharing policies are really quite
deep and complex and I really applaud
them for starting to think through
the implications of that they're much
more aligned with fear than I think any
previous policies and I think having
funding agencies lead from that
perspective it's going to drive all of
that work within uh
grants and contracts that the NIH is
running but that's also going to be true
across all of HHS agencies
I think also adoption and also promotion
in the sense of support for not
promoting individually open data and
Tool standards I think is really
important they're asking people not to
recreate the wheel and develop your own
data schema or tool or data format but
to reuse what's out there already and to
participate in those Community Driven
standards
I think cloud vendors are creating
consistent services that work across
clouds early on the vendors were very
specific to their own clouds and they
did not want to have inter-cloud
connectivity
you can run Services now between clouds
and similar Services run on each Cloud
that makes it a lot more consistent if
you're doing that kind of work
microservices this is another element
where there I think of these as small
functions often apis that Loosely couple
together to accomplish our complex task
so they're not some monolithic system
they're little collections of services
that can do something individually that
you can connect together like Lego
blocks and I think there's uh there's
certainly growth in this area for a
number of different groups that are
building commonses that are using
microservices as these functions to
couple together things rather than to
build monolithic systems and it allows
connectivity by those apis to other
systems
I think there's further development and
improved adoption of the Community
Driven standards and software standards
and integration of those into Cloud
platforms
depositing data in software and open
repositories this includes GitHub but
there are also collections repositories
I know that NIH is looking to
reuse and to deposit data that's coming
out from pis into current repositories
that they already support I think
another element here that's really
important is Citation of data
and that is in journal articles in the
past citation has not been present
there's been no way to do that that's
been changing over time if you can cite
your data in tools and also show where
you've deposited it and that's a
requirement in papers in journal
articles I think that will be incredibly
important for the ReUse of data and
tools it makes a lot easier to find and
actually to reuse if they're following
Fair principles
I think another key one is improved
education of data and infrastructure
issues by organizational organizations
leaderships
often what I found is the leadership
c-suite in commercial organizations but
leadership in government organizations
they're often not that well versed in
data or I.T or systems or infrastructure
or they're only inversed in one
and they're asking their teams within
their organization to help them
understand what they need to do but they
themselves are not very well educated in
that
so what you will end up getting is a
lack of understanding what really needs
to get done they'll drive it to just
outcomes and they won't think about this
interconnectivity and why that's
valuable so if we improve the education
of the organizational leadership I think
this will help it's a great deal in
overcoming some of these problems
I think the last one here is really
important and it touches on what I think
Jack has been trying to drive out with
this series is the use of
interdisciplinary teams if I take it
back to what I just said about
organizational leadership if you have
interdisciplinary teams that work
together if the scientists understand
what the computer scientists are doing
with the computer scientists understand
the science the biomedical science if
you have ethicists working with you if
you have people with different skills
that come together to deliver on a
project and there's an equalness about
their skills it will help Drive
organizations in terms of using their
data per se
those people will lead those parts of
the conversation but those people in
those interdisciplinary teams I think
will also rise to leadership positions
with organizations and that will change
the cultural organizations over time
so I think it's these Collective things
that we're starting to see that I think
is going to change the landscape of the
way that we handle ecosystems and we
drive to interconnectivity in a way
that's meaningful for the community
useful that it still gets to outcomes
and is supported in the incentives
aligned whether you work for Academia or
industry to get to that outcome
right
um getting to just my last slide here
I'd like to thank a number of people
here
um particularly Jack and his team thank
you for the opportunity to speak today
and this great idea of
um
the workshop I'm really looking forward
to going to that I'd also like to thank
Dean fullborn at UVA he and I worked at
NIH together but also we've been working
at UVA and he and I are very interested
in data commonsers and have been
speaking about this for many years and
also especially thank you to Dr Nathan
Sheffield
Nathan wrote a paper recently with some
of the information I provided here is
discussed he's discussed it in way more
detail and the premise of the talk is
really strongly about how microservices
could be one solution to looking at Fair
data and Analysis and I've just included
the reference here and DOI I'd also like
to thank Dr Jurgen Klink who's my
co-lead for the Deloitte biomedical data
science team my entire Deloitte BDS team
who I learned from every single day and
I realize what I don't know
they're a young group of incredibly
enthusiastic fun people to work with
that really do espouse interdisciplinary
approaches and each day I realize my own
blindness so I think that team a great
deal for pointing out things that I need
to learn and I'd also lastly like to
thank many NIH colleagues who I worked
with previously I spent over a decade at
NIH and there are many people at NIH who
really diligently support Fair best
practices they really care about it and
they have a very strong understanding of
it and they come from very strong
biomedical and also compute science
backgrounds and I'm really pleased to
see that NIH is making quite big strides
in this area and it has some fantastic
people that work there that can really
take them to the next next step right I
think that's my last slide Jax so back
to you thank you Vivian that was
wonderful and you will certainly find a
Ally in me about the the strengths and
importance of having a team science
approach in this business biomedicine is
hard enough
um you know by yourself just to keep up
just to be able to understand all that's
going on and so you really need to have
smart people working in those domain
areas where you can turn to them and
have them you know basically just
uncover your blindness rights of what
you're you need to know about I was
impressed when you were talking about
um organizations being born digital and
they'll be defined by their data assets
can you say a little more about that
yeah let me get back to that slide so I
can remind myself what you were saying
there or myself you were saying yeah I
was saying so you're talking about this
one
I'm not seeing your slides at the moment
sorry uh I'm sure it's the same one yeah
this is a digital economy as characters
by using data to gain a business and
manage that much yeah that's the one
yeah
so what I mean by that is I think if
organizations don't so if I get this
right organizations that are not born
digital will be at a disadvantage what I
mean by that is I think organizations
need to understand that they have a lot
of digital assets and they need to
figure out how to leverage those in
order to really be a player in the
digital economy so universities
traditionally have you know there's a
lot of data from experiments but it's
written in a notebook
so there are now electronic notebooks
but how do you share those electronic
notebooks
um it's thinking about everything that
you've got digitally and ensuring that
it is digital so that you can take most
advantage of the data you have that
could be scientific data but it could
also be Enterprise data like student
data information about how many students
attended class you don't take role by
paper anymore you do it digitally I
think these kinds of things give us
insights of data at scale and we need to
think about that broadly across an
organization so I think it really takes
that mindset of thinking digitally from
the outset that's what I mean by born
digital that you really are doing it
from the outset
uh and thinking about that because I
think that's going to give you the
greatest understanding of your own data
and interconnectivity
I certainly think that as we are
collecting more and more data through
you know advances in the various
technologies that you know are in
Laboratories now or that uh
just thinking of like cell sorters and
various other things that are helping us
to uh collect data ever faster Gene
sequencers MRI scanners that data is
being born digitally it used to involve
you know somebody you know doing a lot
of hard work to you know get the data
into a form which would probably pop out
in a in a spreadsheet and now it's you
know
gigabytes and terabytes worth of
information it's itself is born
digitally and so by thinking from the
get-go about those as digital assets
that are themselves born digital and you
are creating an organization or kind of
pivoting your organization to being more
digital is is important and I was
thinking that um this is probably
important as people are entering the
field and things like the NIH strides
program are becoming uh something we
need to attend to and I don't know that
you mentioned it specifically but I'm
curious if you might share what you know
about it
I do know about it but that's mostly
because I used to deal with it from the
inside of NIH but I also have the great
Fortune of working with it now as part
of Deloitte so which part of it would be
the most valuable to you to tell you
what it is or how something else well
what it is what it's
aspirations are and what its current
status might be if you know
sure so first of all I can't represent
NIH but this is just my understanding of
it so strives was born as a way to be
able to provide NIH with access to Cloud
because what had happened over time is
researchers had been using primarily AWS
but some gcp but not under the auspices
of NIH and the problem becomes
particularly cost because academic
institutions and academics can't afford
the commercial prices and it doesn't
make sense at scale so if you're using
part of your Grant to pay for cloud and
you're paying commercial costs and
you're doing it multiple times it just
didn't seem like an economy of scale and
also it made sense since the world is
digitally born right as you pointed out
quite rightly Jack things coming off
machines are born digital yep Cloud was
going to be used more and more so NIH
needed to develop some sort of
relationship in an appropriate way with
the cloud providers that was the driving
force behind it
and then what strides was was to set up
an agreement with Cloud providers it
started with gcp and AWS I believe it's
moved to Azure now where the concept
behind it is that there's a reduced
price for use of compute storage and
services the idea behind it is that it
allows researchers to get a better price
on that
and it's also allowing NIH to to work
better with Cloud providers to
understand what services they do provide
and how they can be better used for
science that's essentially what it does
and it's complicated to get that done
within a government organization but I
think they're making great strides no
pun intended in terms of actually
leveraging that
so that's currently what I know about
stones
what uh
you you talked a little bit about some
of the work that you've done
um with Nathan Sheffield who's a faculty
member here at UVA the stuff that you've
done on microservices or at least
looking at them as a possible solution
um do you feel that microservices are
something that's you know instead of
crafting one big giant all singing all
dancing solution is that if
microservices themselves were granular
enough that people could kind of create
their own workflows through data in a
much more Nimble fashion is that one of
the ideals behind the microservices
movement
yeah and I I urge people to go read the
paper I think he's done a really nice
job of that yes I think the idea behind
it and what he uses in the paper is the
concept of Linux right oh well Unix
right you can run individual service
that in itself is very minor but coupled
together with a bunch of things you can
come up with a very complex workflow and
they're all in the same system using the
same kind of methodologies and that's
the idea also you can mix and match you
may not need every single thing in a
monolithic system
so that those microservices are a way to
Loosely couple things together to
accomplish a complex process
it does still require you to have a
Computing background but it's not
requiring you to be part of a monolithic
service and I certainly know of people
that only want to live the World by
microservices and not monolithic Cloud
platforms but I think there's probably a
happy balance between those since not
all scientists can code or know how to
use an API
what does
um the what do microservices and sort of
the you know cobbling together your own
workflows which is not a bad thing
um but out of microservices what does
that say about data provenance and
reproducibility of processing
well a lot
um I mean if you have a set of services
that are operating on Fair data then and
you also track the provenance I think
that's a good thing to try and do at all
times
um because you'll understand what you
started with and where you came to an
end
so I think that's a really important
aspect of the way that it would handle
it
and also the consistency in the handoff
between those Services if the services
themselves are fair
and I think that that's really critical
in terms of doing that they could also
depending on how you set them up not
handle data provenance they could
actually end up turning this around if
they're not connected well together and
lead to more problems but I think
that's the nature of where we're at I
don't think serve microservices are the
only solution or the solution I think as
I'm saying my last slide they're one of
a collection of things that we have to
try out and then think about the actual
data we're feeding into them to in order
to understand the implications and
impacts of them including on Providence
I want to thank you for sharing your
your thoughts I completely agree about
the role of Team science and why that's
important
do you think that there has been a
cultural shift towards this notion of
Team science here and I mean since more
and more data and organizations are
being born digital we sort of need to
become you know more attuned to what's
going on in fields that are adjacent to
us in contrast to being these like
hyper-specialized people you know that
only really focus on our own thing it's
is there an increased awareness of the
need for data science or sorry team
science as we're performing the data
science that's needed to understand
these complex data sets
it depends it depends on the
organizations I've certainly seen
organizations uh academic and commercial
that see the value of it they realize
that bringing interdisciplinary teams
together helps figure out what problem
they really have
and what they're going to tackle in what
time frame and why I think that's that's
certainly true but I've definitely seen
organizations which are driven by pure
science that pay no attention to the
complexities of the software engineering
or even project management they're
treated as plumbers and when that
happens you tend to drive to use case
driven systems I think of those as
brittle use cases because you build a
system that will handle three use cases
and it won't do a fourth one at all
and the software engineering and the
project management are aligned just with
delivering that but if if it's driven
from a science perspective without
understanding of these other
complexities of software engineering and
pmo project management you get to these
brittle use cases I think it's also
disrespectful to the team's skills not
everyone in the team needs to have a PhD
or an MS right it depends what your
skill is I have many people my team that
don't have they have an undergraduate
degree in whatever
they're very skilled at project
management they're certified as pmps and
they are equally as valuable as someone
who has a PHD or an MS in bioscience
so I think it depends on the
organizations I think we've got a way to
go
I think commercial organizations are
understanding that to drive to an
outcome
um
I'll talk about an Informer and when
you're driving to drug outcomes you know
in terms of new drugs on the market you
need to be able to drive larger data
through cloud and you need to be able to
work in an interdisciplinary team so
that you can get it speeds up what
you're trying to do
they can really help
I think interdisciplinary teams can help
speed the to outcome to get to more
reasonable outcomes that are useful
in a broader sense probably Drive costs
down if they really work effectively
together and I think one of the most
underrated skills is listening if you've
got people with different skills in your
team they're not going to be an engineer
then
they're going to need to understand the
engineer is going to have to be able to
understand how to speak in a language
that's translatable to the person that
isn't
so we have plenty of people in my team
that are explaining the science to the
data scientist about why you need to use
that R code or that python whatever to
do to take an outcome this is what the
science we're trying to do so let's
apply the right code and they're sharing
information all the time it helps our
data scientists who don't have coding
experience understand the complexities
of coding and the coders understanding
why they're actually doing what they're
doing
what sort of advice might you have for
data scientists
um kind of learning about
Commons and Cloud architectures
um who are maybe working in disciplinary
teams with say biologists what sort of
things might they need to know as they
enter into those relationships and
organizations
listening is the most important skill
um realizing that you don't know
everything that your world is not their
world and trying to understand what it
is they're trying to achieve respect for
each one's skills a higher degree does
not mean that you have more skill over
someone else it's the multitude of
skills that come together
[Music]
um
I think the soft skills are really
important in terms of
team science
they're often underrated but for a team
to really work together it's those soft
skills it's often not the hard skills
they have them it's how you bring them
together it's the sharp edges what do
you do when you get to a disagreement or
you don't understand those are the
pieces that you need to bring together
and you need to pay attention to it so
almost you need to leave your coding
skills at the door and start being a
human with another human trying to
figure out how it works
and once you do that then you can bring
the skills to the table often not the
other way around
isn't it interesting that after all of
this technology all of this Advanced
Computing sophisticated Computing
languages and dealing with terabytes
terabytes of data it comes down to a
human human interaction that is really
the end result of all of this uh it's
kind of interesting coming for you know
in a full circle like that
I I agree I think it's it's the human
interactions because I mean we ask
computers to do things we make data Fair
because we want to learn something from
it but it's it's really us as humans
getting together to understand and those
are just tools whether it's a data
Commons
data fairness software you name it those
are tools to help us understand what
we're trying to do but it really comes
down to communication between us in
terms of understanding
what are we trying to get done here with
the set of tools that we need to
accomplish that
it's a really tough one I often
think about this and think
you can
you can say what you want to code it's
not going to fight back unless you
change some line of code but if you
don't have a pleasant conversation with
another human being it can result in a
not a pleasant outcome and you project
can tank maybe because of bad
relationships it's very important I
think to have those soft skills so that
you can find the ways to Quirk with
people that aren't in your field and
then bring the tools to the table not
the other way around
Vivian thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts with us and providing us
with a lot of insights into the role of
Team science into all this complex Cloud
infrastructure that we're certainly uh
if we're if you're not familiar with it
you soon will be
um but it's really important at the end
of the day it's people who are
interested in this we're always
interested in machine learning I think
people learning still has a role in all
of this
um I want to conclude our
biomedical data science seminar series
for uh this particular theme uh on
secondary health effects of covet 19.
um I want to thank Gina camdar and
Hannah kears for being my helpers to
make all of this work so smoothly
um they're the ones responsible for
organizing all of these speakers and for
promoting things on social media and so
none of this would be possible without
them we are really looking forward to
meeting with all of our biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants in
person in Seattle Washington here in a
little more than a month I think having
Vivian there is going to be very
exciting we have other NIH program
officials who are going to be joining us
as well as a slate of really engaged and
enthusiastic mentors so we're really
looking forward to that and I just want
to thank everybody who's joined us over
the last several months to thank you so
much for doing so so I hope you've
learned something and we will look
forward to seeing you all again in the
fall when we start up with whatever our
next theme is going to be we haven't yet
decided yet but we will but in the
meantime everyone have a wonderful Cinco
de Mayo for those of you who observe and
I have a wonderful Friday and a great
weekend and